new stuff is coming - destiny - a
warzone squad has set a massive new
record and respawn has a new studio
Stoli for apex legends i'm persia and
you've reached your save state for
Monday May 18
Zavala voice actor Lance Reddick tweeted
from his at home vo setup which happens
to be in his closet the work from home
blues are real but so is the destiny to
content it seems this teaser comes after
the announcement but Bethany - is coming
to PlayStation 5 and Xbox series X Rhett
it didn't exactly give anything away but
did tell us that some new stuff is
coming at you some new stuff for destiny
that's right
so destiny fans what are you hoping to
see in year 4 a four-player squad in
collar duty warzone has set an
incredible new record of 121 kills and a
quads match Call of Duty streamers TP
send funny Huskers and Dougie's raw
showcased amazing movement both in the
air and on the ground constant
communication and obviously great shots
to not only get the victory but break a
wild world record there are only 150
players in a given warzone matchin they
got a hundred and twenty one of them we
don't know what the previous record was
but this is gonna be pretty hard to be
you can catch that full match up on
GameSpot calm in other Battle Royale
news Respawn Entertainment is
celebrating its 10-year anniversary and
it just opened up a brand new studio in
Vancouver solely for Apex legends
there's already an EA Vancouver campus
so apex game director Chad Grenier hopes
the proximity to other EA developers
will give the apex team more resources
to work with which could help the game
grow the most recent update to the game
is season 5 fortunes favor which
introduces changes to Kings Canyon and
adds a quest system a new battle pass a
new legend named lobha and a variety of
updates to the existing characters we
already have all the coverage and tips
you're gonna need to conquer season 5 on
our channel so make sure you check that
out that's all for today but make sure
you reach your saves date for tomorrow
I'm Persia and you can follow me on twit
at Persia underscore X oh happy Monday